[Musique]
Si tu es ici
tu connais le cas
d'alessandro ils répliquent
ensuite
[Musique]
n
après avoir inclus les frais
alors tout de suite
[Musique]
à ce sujet
mais c'est encore le recensement
[Musique]
J'étais un produit de sexe unique
nous sommes ici du chili c'est un
caricaturé que
rien de moins
[Musique]
Oui
Oh
ceux qui passent un bon moment
[Musique]
deux
et
ou non
honnêtement
et jusqu'à
avoir les trains
Est-ce que le jeu
[Musique]
avec cette recherche
cette
[Musique]
est
par derrière
[Musique]
jamais
non
Oui
intégré le sermon
A refusé
non
Alors
un peu
[Musique]
Sont fréquents
un autre gène ici ne sont pas en reste paroles
9 heures
l'électricité
Oui
cette ville
et
majeur
deux
ef
Oh
une idole que tout le monde
nous éviterons de donner
deux
[Musique]
comme ça
Oui
On y va
transpirer une fin
[Musique]
ce feu
que la faim qu'ils font de lui était la
la condition était qu'il existe ou qu'on ait signé
deux
il h
Ça existe
[Musique]
m
est-ce
Oui
[Musique]
et dans cette équation
recherche plus complexe
Oui
avec des dépressions brille cette wii
Je sais que cette société publique et le
lequel pas
Oui
pour un exercice
[Musique]
Oui
deux
son cas a obtenu l'éternel
Oui
Ça marche
et pour moi
sixième
3 en 1
à la cale en 3 secondes
[Applaudissements]